when teams play man you need your
players to make place and that's really
what happened today we had a quarterback
that has that stepped up and made throws
and gave our guys chances and then when
the chance was there to make a play
they made place and I think that's where
we finally feel like yeah okay we know
we can do this Matt Negi coach of the
six and six bears every week I look at
their record and I think how are they
that good because they're supposed to be
horrible because that's been the
narrative for most of the season the
Bears can't do anything you can't move
the ball but your Biscay stinks Matt
Negi doesn't know what he's doing and
now here we are tables set now look it's
a tough run the rest of the way but I
got to give the Bears credit going to
Thanksgiving the short week the
traditional Thanksgiving game for the
lines and yeah it was David Blau at
quarterback not Matt Stafford not Jeff
Driskel but the Bears hung in there they
were down early they came back they win
the game they moved to six and six and
as you said Mitch strabinsky great drive
to pull out the victory he was 29 a 38
338 yards three touchdowns one pick and
the Bears they're there they're there
they're kind of back oh look at that
this is a glass half-full glass
half-empty situation Mike because you
say you look at the Bears record and you
say how are they this good I oh I look
at it and say how are they this bad this
team I don't understand how do they lose
some of the early games that make them a
6 and 16 and not you know an 8 and 4
team or a team that could be looking at
a no-doubter playoff run right here mr.
Biscay was phenomenal on that last drive
I think mr. Brisky is probably wouldn't
you say gets the most hate online of any
quarterback at this present moment
wouldn't you say that's fair to say
oh it's fair to say because every bears
fans thinking we could have had two
Shaun Watson or Patrick my home yeah
okay you get the external criticism and
you've got that luck the lament of the
Bears fans saying my god what did we do
we could have one of the best
quarterbacks in the NFL right now
instead we've got this guy we're trying
to you know paste together with duct
tape and glue and look I'm not I've said
it many times I don't think mr. risk
he's the guy but I'm gonna when he does
you know good things on the field
wins games like he did yesterday he
deserves credit so I think it's fair to
give him credit he was great yesterday
he had he had a few drives there where
he looked very very good including the
last one where the Bears needed a
touchdown he went down the field he
threw it shorty to it long he did
everything the only criticism I had of
him yesterday was he made a couple
business decisions with his feet then it
felt like he could get some extra yards
and maybe some first downs but that's
that hip that's that Matt Nagy hip we've
been talking about that's why he benched
him in LA and for no other reason than
that but yeah that one was maddening
right there when he clearly had the
first out Mike in all seriousness I
don't think the Bears are a very good
football team but a boy can dream and if
you look at the skin Jerry Jones you're
just young Jerry Jones that's me that's
fine I can be Jerry Jones Jerry Jones
shouldn't be me Jerry Jones shouldn't be
big now they're 7 and 6 now they're
their December schedule is very very
tough they have to play the Vikings they
have to play the Packers they have to
play the Chiefs and I'm forgetting a
team on their Cowboys Packers chase
Vikings so ok so actually I think
they're gonna make the playoffs yeah now
that I've talked myself into it they
just gotta go three in one nine in seven
the Vikings trip up a couple times if
they beat the Vikings again in week 17
that's two against the Vikings
it can happen Mike crazier things have
happened
they you know it I'm just I'm gonna get
my heart broken again I've got my heart
broken like seven different times the
thing yeah
hey listen teams constantly say we want
to win the Super Bowl we want to win the
Super Bowl and you have to say that I
think the true measure of success for a
team is being relevant after
Thanksgiving and the Bears aren't
relevant after Thanksgiving now they are
you at least get a week after
Thanksgiving into the Christmas season
to feel like the Bears have a chance and
even if they lose to the Cowboys next
week you still get another week and a
half to think there's still a way to
make this work there's still a way to
run the table and get to nine and seven
and get in so that's what that's the
wish for every team and that's the
with this year because there's like 12
teams that are just done at this point
right yeah and yeah and that's too many
for the NFL to beat and look at the
stadiums for some of these teams but
that's the key
relevance after Thanksgiving in the
Bears earned at the past two weeks I
agree with you I'm ready to be heard
again I also and we can talk about this
in the second hour but I think this
saves Matt Negi and mr. whiskey's job
next year and I'm okay with that Mike
I'm actually okay with that
well and now the question is will they
pick up the option on true Biscay and
met
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports